on est différente des hommes en tant que
femme est vraisemblablement en tant que
cinéaste
[Musique]
pendant des années
bon c'était le cinéma hollywoodien qui
nous a mené sa la femme était
mystérieuse la femme était vue d'une
façon très en même temps idéalisé parce
que magnifiquement belle et en même
temps pas du tout dans son quotidien pas
c'était une vision d'homme peut être une
vision idéalisée pour le spectateur une
vision fausse aujourd'hui pas seulement
les femmes et les hommes aussi montrent
les femmes au trône un regard de femme
une sensibilité de femme c'est pas
pareil
et enfin ils ne diront pas de la même
façon c'est ça qui bien si c'est qu'on
n'est pas pareil elles ont certainement
autre chose à dire il y a il ya une
culture différente forcément parce qu'on
a des statuts économiques sociaux
différents donc on a un oeil de
coloniser sur le chemin qui est là un
oeil beaucoup plus subversif beaucoup
plus
un résoudrait que vous disiez hameau du
choix de vos actrice qui ne sont pas des
jolies filles aux 100 hollywoodien du
terme bien sûr le producteur les gens de
la télévision même l'opérateur au début
était est pas d'accord que je prends par
exemple qu'il en est le personnage
principal lorsque disney s'écroule pas
du tout le genre les grosses un un
personnage keller une pas besoin de
béquilles caire d'avoir besoin de plaire
pour exister si vous voulez je cherche
l'âme je cherche la personnalité
derrière de visas est aussi une sorte de
révolte des femmes cinéastes qui peuvent
changer son vous savez je suis un
cinéaste j'espère être un cinéaste point
final les choses qui m'intéressent sont
plus sûrement des choses de femmes je
crois qu'on me donnerais n'importe
quelle histoire j'y mettrai
inconsciemment ce qui m'obsède le plus
qui est ça et qui est quand même une
préoccupation essentiellement de femmes
puisque c'est la maternité
je pose pas la question je vais faire un
film de femmes je pense que je parle de
moi c'est vrai qu'ils parlent beaucoup
moi et donc je parle d'une femme puisque
je suis une femme dans le cinéma j'ai
pas encore vu un film ou même une image
un moment oui je me dise c'est parce que
c'est une femme que ça me que c'est
différent je n'ai encore jamais vu les
hommes sont un peu vu de manière
peut-être schématique de la même manière
que nous on est très schématique sida
j'ai pas l'impression afin d'avoir cinq
films de femmes j'ai l'impression
d'avoir fait un film
il se trouve que je suis une femme
points en général les toulonnais sujet
la perception sont différents des hommes
mais aussi différents de l'une à l'autre
je crois pas qu'il va y avoir un fou et
ma des femmes et qu'on va retrouver des
caractéristiques de chat d'un film dans
tous les autres films c'est socialement
il faudrait que les gens aillent voir
des films au fond ils devraient pas
savoir tellement si c'est une femme ou
un homme qu'il a fait et ça ne devrait
pas tellement être jugé comme tel et je
crois que mes films sont tous au vin
télé qu elle y porte peut-être des idées
mais les idées souvent jeudi remarques
après que le film soit le fait quand il
fait des films que je fais sont
sensuelles
santi physique une des différences c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de femmes qui soient
pour le moment enfin des façonniers des
gens qu'on peut appeler en disant voilà
j'ai un sujet j'aimerais que vous le
fassiez avec alain delon et mireille
darc que je trouve assez épuré beau dans
leur démarche c'est c'est de vouloir
faire un cinéma par forcément
intellectuelle mais personnelles et
sensibles et évidemment c'est plus dur
aussi dans l'industrie telles qu'elles
existent en ce moment jacques clouseau
vous êtes un réalisateur ou une
réalisatrice anne ont maintenant une
réalisatrice ça ça m'a toujours fait
rire et ça me fera encore plus rien
[Musique]